thwip whip reject nation we got some
spider-man stuff to react to today gonna
be two videos going up so this video we
wanted to do a dedicated one to the
bridge fight the most teased action
sequence of all time his damn bridge
fight
the main main promotion
gotland together at last and it's mainly
just spidey versus doc
way too ahead of yourself there toby's
there he's andrew and the next video
that's gonna go up today there's a
couple like three new tv spots and then
another clip called peter ruins runes i
think it was called but first let's kick
it off today with this one only just a
few more days people
[Music]
hello peter
hi
do i know you what have you done with my
machine
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know what machine
do you want to play games
[Music]
cool
cool
whoa
come on
that was great yeah
i really feel like john watts is
stepping up his direction this time
around you know like the first
spider-man homecoming it wasn't uh it
was like more simple in the way it was
shot the action was very memorable but i
think with the characters he's
inheriting especially
from the raimi films in particular
because i see a lot of conversation that
arises from a lot of people kind of
actually prefer the swinging from the
amazing spider-man then when it comes to
the direction of action scenes of camera
placement movement perspective a lot
goes to sam raimi and i think with all
the characters he's getting here
especially if you're gonna bring doc ock
back and have spider-man versus doc ock
with this train sequence fight that
whole so you're starting from the
building going to the train you're going
to want to really amp up your direction
level so it's all seems really present
here i feel like he's probably very
conscientious
about that going to this one if you're
going to call this one your spider-man
end game film with this fight in
particular with doc ock throwing a car
she's talking to john about this the
other day
because he had that shot here is like
he's throwing a lot at him here a big
famous moment from spider-man 2 is when
toby is sitting across from kirsten
dunst and they're about to kiss again
and then the spider says it's activated
as a car it goes through then to the
coffee shop it's great
visually beautiful tense sequence and i
love the way that whole thing is
captured but it really hit me on a
re-watch we're going a little side
touching here james franco sent doc ock
after him because he's like if you want
to find spider-man go through peter
parker dalcock has no idea that that is
spider-man he thinks he's just trying to
get peter parker he doesn't know he's
spider-man he doesn't so why would he
throw a car at him so he threw a car at
him and he killed him and just splat
and it's like who went a little too far
yeah i really thought he would get the
get the heads up
just trying to send a message yeah yeah
went a little too far accidentally
killed a bunch of people in that coffee
shop not to mention the property dude
and also the beyonce of that famous
astronaut
too you got a lot working against me
right now but anyway uh yeah visually
that's what i thought a lot of this was
hearkening back to you know using a
bunch of items around you to toss at
your spider-man and like a love certain
perspective shots here like when he puts
out his uh to thwip cameraman's here as
he's running like a pov shot
or that shot with that woman in the car
and then how it's like locked on the
dashboard as it's falling over yeah you
feel like you're in the car looking back
at her almost
yeah i mean this was really nice and
punchy and i mean this feels like
another scene that has been pared down
but conscientiously because aside from
the cut from the tentacle hitting the
ground to hello peter everything pretty
much played smoothly and yeah it really
struck me in that one big shot where you
know rock is tromping over the highway
throwing thing after thing and peter and
it's all just like one big movement like
that was an instance in which i was like
okay like i can see partly how and why
they're using the cg approach to this to
enhance the intensity of the action with
doc ock because you know you're at
peter's ground level and you get a lot
more mobility to kind of yeah keep it
locked down there but also you know
relish in the cool just sci-fi quality
that that action has and yeah it made me
wonder cause i mean she calls him peter
it sounds like as the car's falling over
the side of the off-ramp there and you
know either the spell hasn't worked or
this is like before the spell or
something like that but you know that
was like a little context clue that was
interesting well
from previous shots he was standing with
his suit on
and then he was is looking at her in the
through the car window before like in
the other trailers we've seen that a lot
of people theorize about who she might
be is it miles's mom sort of a lot of
people
i think what we know is that's not
miles's mom
i don't remember if they actually came
out and said who she was but it could
just be another character who just
happens to know or perhaps the spell
didn't indeed work but she is calling
out to him yeah in fact it kind of
reminds me of the amazing spider-man
scene uh a scene that i think a lot of
people really love there's a person
hanging off a car a little boy and
that's when he like gets on top takes
off his mask you were you were the mask
you'd be spiderman you're gonna be fine
actually i'd say that whole sequence
from amazing spider-man when he's first
chasing down lizard on the freeway
catching the cars is reminiscent an
amazing spider-man also had all those
pov shots of him using the web shooters
too which you see in this one sequence
here so you got these like little
connections of course you have dr
octopus showing up saying where's my
machine plugged right out of the events
of spider-man 2. he's talking about his
fusion reactor looking for that right
away in case you guys didn't know what
machine he could possibly be alluded to
it's only that one that he's talking
about and i think at one point too we
heard dr uh dr octopus's theme yeah yeah
a little bit of that motif in the very
beginning yeah it's beautiful to hear
again one that's the other thing that's
going to be really exciting is you've
got to imagine that every villain's
theme will be worked in and i mean you
know we can surmise that the spider
themes will work their way in the
villain themes have to work their way in
and there's some really great you know
work across those old movies especially
the sam raimi movies danny elfman's
scores are pretty great another thing
that makes me really uh think back too a
little bit more towards the raimi films
or the films of prime so used to like
these comic book movies having a lot of
heavy cgi fights and so as well you're
getting a good amount of cgi here with
the way doc ox moving and such it looks
great but i love when it blends it with
practicality like i really feel like
these cars are on set or especially when
they do lunge the car a cg car when
they're doing those shots but then it
goes into those offices water barrels
yeah
you really feel the impact of it that
looks like physical effects yeah yeah
and there's something about this whole
fight and just even being on the freeway
would just park cars around and they
shoot a lot of that stuff low until it
you know makes a lot of sense to cut to
an aerial so it really feels like
they're grounding that fight and yeah
especially with those like little pov
shots thrown in it makes you feel like
it's a little more intense and a little
more like ground level visceral
absolutely absolutely it's just cool
it's cool it's only going to be longer
and better yeah i mean yeah this has to
be expanded in the actual movie and i
love the stakes too of him trying to
rescue someone as well again back to
spider-man 2 where he's fighting doc
hawk and having to rescue people yeah
while he's throwing them around and
stuff you know but it reminds you of
like yes you have your big villains to
deal with but he's also trying to be a
hero well i think that for spider-man is
especially important like you know
that's something that often times in
superhero movies can get overlooked in a
way where i'm like oh man i wish they
had them like actually interacting with
or saving just people but i feel like
especially for spider-man that's a
really important element too so i love
that yeah this is being grounded and
even with that clip on on on the opening
scene you know he's got to be like oh
wait i gotta go you know secure mj yeah
you know so it has that yeah also just
uh the quality of saving saving
somebody's life stakes all right guys
well what did you think about this clip
leave your thoughts down below oh can't
wait can't wait subscribe hit that
notification bell hit that like button
catch you guys soon